die wüsten der meister der müsste schon
längst da sein früher um unserem heute
schon tabu
mit zehn mann haben drei tage lang
bewacht damit die eingeworfenen
steinheim kinder diese grabler diesmal
laufen ist euch gang hat drei tag und
nacht um die ehre weil ihnen die
eilendorfer den maibaum gestohlen hätten
das war die größte schande ist krisen
dina und das passiert eben immer war
jetzt besteht dass ein maibaum im
internet und der maibaum de du und dann
konnte er super express lieferung dinge
zum aufstellplatz
da ist da schon der fakt kaputt
dieses paket
wir haben in zwei stunden maibaumfeier
ich hab eigentlich freiheit an meiner
besteht also der maibaum hat er war
gestern schon dabei war da war ja keiner
dann habe ich ihn im nachbarort in
inheiden dorf abgegeben
bestellen sie jetzt ihren maibaum auf
maibaum de wir liefern egal wann egal
wohin und golfer nicole wohin die sich
nicht egal
die jetzt besser papa free besser
[Applaus]